let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 and see what is on people's
minds starting with our caller from the
2 4 0 area code who's calling today from
2 4 0 where are you calling from Rob I'm
calling from Maryland hey Rob what's up
so I have I've always worked at small
businesses I've always resisted going to
big corporate places for work because I
know that I would I would suffer it
would be spirit-crushing I prefer places
where rather than there being a very
established culture the place has a
malleable personality that I can
actually come in and contribute to ok
and because and because I work for those
types of places I'm unemployed right now
and and it's looking less and less
likely that those types of places are
going to come back after the dust
settles because you know they they
typically have much lower margins that
they're running on that if they miss a
month of profit they they can't keep up
and so now I'm very reluctantly applying
to you know the safe ways and the cbs's
and the Burger Kings of the world
because that's all that's going to be
left after this and we're also kind of
creating an entire generation of you
know the the young people right now who
are seeing that they really only have
three kind of options as far as career
paths if they want their careers to be
pandemic proof they can either go into
public service like government health
care or education they can go into they
can go work for massive fast food chain
or
a grocery store or they can get one of
those corporate jobs where they can work
from home and those are diminishing ly
rare I mean those are the jobs of our
parents generation not ours and so we
are going to you know for for a long
time have this shift I think that that
crushes the dreams of a lot of people
who may have been better in
non-essential fields such as cosmetology
or the arts or culinary or you know
being in research fields of academia
where you have to actually go somewhere
to study something and I wanted to know
just if you had any ideas about how how
we could incentive eyes or it or if this
is even a good thing like should
unnecessary jobs just disappear and if
not how how do we incentivize people to
still follow their dreams so there's a
lot there Rob and so first of all I I
don't know that I agree with you about
the jobs that are pandemic proof I mean
what we just learned this week about the
nearly 5% GDP reduction in the first
quarter and half of that GDP reduction
was in health care which is
counterintuitive because with so many
coronavirus patients what how could that
be it's because almost all non-emergency
health care has been shut down and it
certainly has not been pandemic proof
for people who work in dermatology
offices and the like so I don't totally
agree with the premise but what I would
tell you is just because a job is not
essential in a pandemic doesn't mean
it's not an essential job so as an
example transportation is essential to
99.99% of
human existence we're in a pandemic
shutdown where people aren't travelling
so everything from from you know cab
drivers to airline pilots are suffering
right now but I would not want to
disincentivize people from working in
those fields because they're so
important 99.99% of the time what we
need to do is we need to be more take be
more proactive as I spoke about on the
Wednesday show this week about softening
the blow to a lot of these industries
and by that I mean to the workers not to
like the hedge fund people that are
speculating in these businesses we need
to have an economic system that's more
proactively protecting them but the last
thing I would say is hey during however
long this is if it's two months if it's
nine whatever it is to say there were
jobs that weren't really useful during
that time these are jobs that are
absolutely necessary to society 99.99%
of the time and I would not suggest
people abandon them we just need to be
better prepared to deal with situations
like this my friend I'm gonna let you go
because I have so many people that that
want to get on but it's an important
question and I'm glad that you asked it